hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to handless millionaire I am
sorry for the delay in this game I just
got back from Boston for PAX East which
was absolutely awesome and I met so many
guys and I had two different panels
there and I had a lot of signings and I
did a lot of stuff almost too much stuff
because it didn't actually get to play
many games while I was there but I did
get to play this one game called Orcs
Must Die and this isn't it obviously but
if you haven't checked out the new Orcs
Must Die MOBA it's absolutely phenomenal
and I love Orcs Must Die in fact that
played it a long time ago with my
brother so if you want to see baby mark
with my prepubescent voice and all of my
not long hair and ass and handsome this
you can check out an old video that I
did way back when the description below
with my brother but this is not that
game and also a millionaire spelled
incorrectly so this game that we're
playing right now that's not Orcs Must
Die or anything to do with PAX East is
where you're trying to get money out of
this guillotine and it's very
death-defying and dangerous and
apparently this is totally worth it
because I don't know about you I would
never ever ever ever risk any part of my
body just to get money and I wouldn't
even make it up to five hundred thousand
or a million regard I would never ever
ever oh I was playing this game just to
test it out I got to like 20 and I I
didn't lose any appendages but then
again I was concentrating very much and
not trying to I'm not trying to talk
who's doing it so it was actually
incredibly stressful because I don't
want to lose my hand because I do things
and stuff with that hand I'm gonna be
able to handle this game
yeah okay all right my god it's a simple
pattern it's all about pattern
recognition and quickness okay there's
like double-double patterns and I don't
know if I'm supposed to be able to got
to be careful is that a real bill does
that actually exist it probably does but
I've never seen one okay that's that's
the opening it's good I don't know oh
man you really got to recognize the
pattern or else you know that's not a is
that a real thing is there really a
thousand dollar bill I'd like to see
that one in my lifetime all right that
one was easy because it was the one at
the end of it that was recognizable and
I was able to do it
now if it just goes totally random
patterns I'm gonna be prone
oh come on oh I'm so ginger about it I'm
doing great this is great this is
totally worth it
let's totally worth it oh let's fake
money's not worth it no no I'm stressed
it's not my hand but okay that's the gap
I don't go what I think it's about to
happen I should be fine oh my god
a hundred thousand dollars that cannot
be a real bill there's no way that
actually exists there's another gap why
is this guy's hand all twitchy like that
I'm trying to pay attention here I'm
worried Daisy's gonna put that big ugly
fingernail and stop it man stop stop
twitching
Wow thought that last one was a hundred
thousand the night just I just got the
hundred thousand it's in the pile that's
the exact same one that's in the pile I
have that why I have it maybe he didn't
expect me to get this far and maybe I
just gotta stay a hundred thousand level
for my pile doesn't even have a hundred
thousand ated what is this ball okay now
I'm at the five thousand oh now I've
earned it all my money's wait that's not
five hundred thousand this game is
bugged okay okay okay okay okay I don't
even know what's going on now it's not
even a number up there what's going on
what is the what maybe it really didn't
expect me to get this far
not even on the board one stopped moving
like that you don't you're gonna toss
everything around I know you're losing
blood very quickly but seriously this is
not okay
stop okay it's the same thing it's not a
thing oh god I'm getting woozy from all
the blood loss
I just want to win forgive it two
million six hundred and sixty six
thousand dollars Oh God stop losing I
know all my blood is out of my body
dude stop dude stop dude seriously stop
right now stop stop
I'm sweating I'm soon
I'm off the board now I'm off the screen
okay I want three point six six six
eight million dollars okay for me and
yet I don't have I don't have a long
sleeved shirt so I can't do the magic
trick that you all are very impressed by
anyway Oh God my voice already it's been
a long long convention weekend and I
used my voice a lot this weekend so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching prepare for a little video than
I'm gonna make like a vlog or something
to tell you how pax was but I'm also
preparing for South by Southwest gaming
at the end of this weekend I'm gonna be
gone from Thursday to Sunday so I'm
gonna be pretty busy over the next few
days but thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the end today some
more cool videos that I've done if you
haven't seen it the five nights at
Freddy's compilation is like the
funniest video that's ever been put on
my channel and I have to thank cyndago
for making that for me they put all the
work in while I was away I asked him to
do it and they were more than happy they
did a fantastic job it you won't regret
it it's one of the funniest videos I've
ever seen so thank you again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video